- [Host] Let's get started
with our first topic.
Very interested if folks
aren't familiar with Ninja One,
very cool software, can
help with IT operations
for your organization.
I'm excited for our next
speaker, Jeff Hunter,
talking a little bit
about how to get it right
as it pertains to leveraging AI
and AI in the context of
operations in a scalable format.
So without further ado, Jeff.
- Thank you very much.
Hello everyone. My name is Jeff Hunter.
I'm the field CTO at a
company called Ninja One.
I'm always curious who has heard of us.
So just a quick show of hands,
who has heard of Ninja One,
maybe knows what we do?
Bonus points if you're
an actual user. Okay.
Ninja One makes all
the tools that you need
to manage devices, IT teams
need to manage devices.
And so this could be to patch
your devices, this could be
to alert whenever there's
some sort of issue.
This could be to patch software,
and it can be to remotely
access devices via screen share
so you can help solve
problems in real time.
And we do that across Windows,
across Mac OS, across Linux,
across iOS, iPad OS, and Android devices.
And having a platform to
manage all of these devices
is really important because
businesses run on endpoints
more now than they ever have
at any point in modern history.
Now, we're all used to an
endpoint that could be a typical
laptop or a server, but they could also be
manufacturing equipment in factories.
They could be ticket kiosks,
they could be the digital billboards
that you see on the side of the road,
and in my own personal experience,
they are the movie theater projectors
that we see movies on
when we go to the cinema.
And on average we're touching about four
or more of these devices
every day just as a part
of our regular work lives.
And these devices all need to be secured
and they all need to be
supported over the course
of that device's lifecycle.
Now, to compound this issue,
the last five years have been the biggest,
most seismic sea change
in the IT industry ever.
Overnight organizations had to accommodate
to people working remotely,
not working in an office,
being all over different
geographic locations.
And it has been a slow journey
to put the toothpaste back in the tube
on that particular front.
We still see a ton of hybrid
and remote work persisting
even more than five years
after it first really
begins in earnest in 2020.
And as always seems to
happen, this means IT teams
have to do more with less.
So more users to support, and
those users are also spread
apart geographically in a way that they
have not traditionally been.
And there are more
devices to cover as well
as those devices being of
more varying types of devices,
not kind of the traditional laptop
and server that we're very familiar with.
And this is all happening in
an era with a ton of merger
and acquisition activity,
shifting compliances,
different auditing standards,
and those all need to be
adhered to and accounted for.
In my experience, it seems like IT teams
almost have to massively
overproduce in order
to meet whatever their goals happen to be.
I would compare it to trying
to roast a marshmallow
over the campfire except you're
50 feet above the campfire.
You have to produce an
enormous amount of energy
just to get a little bit of a
heat to go to the right spot.
Now the solution for inefficiency
is being more efficient.
Groundbreaking, I know.
But really what we want to do is bring
that marshmallow a little
closer to the fire.
I promise I'll abandon that metaphor now.
But really we want to
take our more easy issues
and we want to automate them entirely.
We want to take our more
difficult, time consuming
and multi-step trouble shooting processes
and we want to streamline them.
We want to minimize the
need for human involvement
as much as possible.
And so now we introduce
AI into the equation.
I have had conversations with thousands
of IT teams over the past five years
and there are certain themes,
you know, common needs,
common questions that
start to emerge as a part
of those many conversations.
And one of the questions I
think I've heard more than any
other is, "What are you doing with AI?"
Now, fundamentally what
that question is asking
is, "How are you taking this
new and exciting technology,
what I view as fundamentally a new tool,
and how are you applying that
to the product's specific area of focus?"
Now, in the early days of AI
bursting into the mainstream,
my question was, "What
would you feel comfortable
putting in the hands of an AI?"
Because there's a ton of potential
for applying AI based systems
and methodologies into
endpoint management.
Ninja One's very first foray
into an AI feature was scraping
public data from the internet
on the sentiment about
different Windows patches.
Whenever somebody has a big
uptick in complaints about
a particular Windows
KB, that's a sign that
that patch is causing problems.
And so what we do is we
summarize all of that data
in a brief description right in the menu
where you actually approve those patches
so you have a quick and
easy way to be able to tell,
is this patch going to cause more problems
than it's actually able to solve?
This is a great application of AI.
We all know it's great at
taking a massive amount of data,
condensing it into an
easy to digest snippet.
But there's also the possibility
of AI taking more direct action.
Now that's the ambition, that's the dream,
that AI is going to be
able to perform autonomous
endpoint management
where you're able to have
the first touch responding
to an issue come from the AI
or from the system that's been set up,
and the first touch is not
necessarily a human being
who has to be directly involved.
Now again, that's the the
ambition, that's the dream,
but AI is of course a
brand new technology,
and with any new
technology, quite honestly,
any technology period,
there is a lot of risk.
It's just that as that technology evolves,
we tend to view the risk as
more of a known quantity.
Obviously an AI is only as good
as the documentation that it's trained on.
And if that documentation is wrong,
if the information it's
trained on is out of date,
if the data set is incomplete,
the AI is going to draw
the wrong conclusions,
and then the human being
who is using that AI
is going to amplify
those wrong conclusions
and spread misinformation.
In my experience, correcting that type
of misinformation is really difficult.
People latch onto their first impression,
so what they hear first it sets
in their minds like concrete
and it can be very, very
difficult to chisel it out.
Now this type of risk, if we apply that
to an endpoint management platform,
I think we're magnifying the potential
for undesired outcomes in
a pretty substantial way.
At a core level, this is a
marriage of a very powerful tool,
which an endpoint management
platform has to be by design,
and the marriage of an AI
that gives you the ability
to make decisions very quickly.
I would say we probably
all agree in this room,
it's a bad idea to make
bad decisions quickly.
That's the last thing that you want to do.
For example, there are other
endpoint management tools
that give you the capability
to actually generate
code, generate scripts
inside of the platform.
This can be really convenient,
but think about deploying
a script generated by an AI
to all of your devices, and the
AI decides that the shortest
distance between A and B
when it comes to freeing up
additional disc space
is just to delete stuff,
just to run the format
system drive command.
It's about the the last thing
we would want to have happen.
And so in using any AI
tool, we have to ask ourself
not just one question, but many questions.
For example, is there a
repeatable process in place
to make sure that we're able
to update the information
that the AI is making decisions
on on a regular basis?
Going to my earlier example, the Ninja One
patch intelligence AI feature.
Obviously when we're
scraping for data on patches,
that's going to fluctuate over time.
And so we need to be able
to take that into account
that the sentiment might not be negative
when the patch is first
released, but as more data
comes into the system, we are more aware
that the patch could be bad.
And we also need to plan for
what is the worst case scenario
that could arise from misuse
or a bad implementation of AI.
And as a part of that planning,
we have to ask ourselves
what guardrails are in
place to ensure that
that does not happen?
And if something does happen
that is undesired, how
is that decision making
process tracked?
How can we track and audit
to know how we arrived
at that particular decision
so that adjustments can be made
to prevent that in the future?
I wanna talk just briefly
about a few categorizations
of AI use in terms of how that's applied
to endpoint management.
I'm sure we're all very
familiar with generative AI.
Everyone here has used
Co-pilot, Gemini ChatGPT
at one point or another.
We've all asked it to do something.
We've all asked it to, you know,
answer a question of some sort.
Now flipping the switch,
we have agentic AI.
So this is then taking
action, performing actions,
performing a routine task,
ideally without the
involvement of a human being.
For example, maybe a ticket
comes into a help desk
and the ticket is recognized
as a common problem
with a known solution.
If we automatically apply
that solution to the problem,
to the ticket as a first step
before we actually escalate
to a human technician,
that is an a great way to streamline
and save time as a part
of the help desk process.
However, the danger becomes
a lack of adequate guardrails
around the action that you're taking.
In my example, I mentioned
applying a known solution
to a problem, and I say a known solution
because the danger of an ad
hoc generated on the spot
AI based solution is pretty great.
When you do that, you could be
exacerbating the problem more
than you're actually solving it.
I don't know if anybody's ever tried
to ask an LLM the same
question multiple times.
You often sometimes get five similar
answers, maybe a little similar.
You might get five answers
that are really different,
but it's pretty rare to get
the exact same identical answer
every single time you ask that question.
I don't think anybody's getting
five out of five on that.
And that's of course because
that answer is being, you know,
generated in real time.
And then on the predictive AI front,
this is obviously taking a
massive amount of data in
and then giving us insight
into what the future health
of the device looks like
and helping us prevent future
problems from occurring.
And so in action we see this
in terms of taking a ticket,
summarizing the ticket
that we are seeing there
and then potentially even
producing a potential answer
to that ticket.
In Ninja One , we see this
with our AI assistant,
it's called Katana 'cause we
do everything ninja themed.
And so that is an AI
assistant that we have
that's in a beta right now.
We also see it in the form
of that patch intelligence
AI feature that I mentioned earlier.
This is surfacing data about patches
when there's problems so
that you know about it.
But then we take it a step
further in terms of more
of an agentic AI approach to
where we're actually taking
those patches that have negative sentiment
and we're removing them
from the deployment queue.
So they're actually not going
to even deploy those patches.
It's going to reserve
it so that a human being
can look at it and decide if
this is actually applicable
to my devices or not.
And then of course, we can
predict what is going to happen
to devices in the future based
off of historical trends.
And so we have, we're
working towards a world
where we can track historical
data for CPU, for RAM,
measure the digital user's
experience on the endpoint,
and then give a stoplight system,
so green, everything is good,
yellow, maybe everything is
not so good on the device.
And then red, the digital user experience
is severely degraded.
That gives us insight into
how all of our end users
are being impacted by the
performance of their devices.
Now there is certainly
a narrative around AI
that I've heard a lot of, which is
that it is about replacing people.
Of course there's always
the extent to which
that's going to be true in certain jobs
and in certain industries.
But I would also say
that a true replacement
of a sizable chunk of
the workforce is against
historical trends.
The industrial revolution
was a long time ago.
There's been a lot of
inventions since the cotton gin
and we all still have jobs, you know,
we're just not farmers.
The invention of the assembly line,
that may have looked at the
time like that was going to be
a process that eliminated
the need for people
to be involved in things
like manufacturing
cars and different goods.
I think we now know that that
is not necessarily the case.
So at Ninja One, we definitely recognize
the tremendous power of AI based tools,
but we also strongly
believe that the value
of those tools comes from
being tied to the human beings
who are actually going to be using them.
Because if we look at the
different categorizations of AI
that we've discussed, what we
end up with is the potential
for a really powerful automation engine.
Again, where that first
touch is not going to be
a human being being involved,
it's going to be trying
all the attempted solutions,
the possible solutions
that we view as safe and
seeing if that fixes the issue
before we then elevate to a human being.
And the goal is to help
scale with business growth.
The goal is to improve the
device footprint, the number
of devices that a technician
can effectively manage.
But human beings are
fundamentally an intrinsic part
of endpoint management, even as automation
and AI might change the
day-to-day duties for those
who are working on the help desk.
And so in this context, we
need AI to be a reliable tool.
When somebody picks up that
tool, we need it to work.
Not every AI is created equal
and not every AI is
going to be equally adept
at your real world workflows.
If you give somebody a fillips
head screwdriver when they
need a flat head, you're pretty close,
but it's still not quite right.
And in the same light, using
a generic LLM is not likely
to give you the good experience
that you are going to get
from something that's purpose
built for the specific
area of focus that we're
working in in that given moment.
Quite honestly, people don't use tools
that they don't trust,
and in the very least,
they tend not to use
those tools very well.
And so it's important
to know how did an AI
come to a particular decision or outcome.
The air handling of an
AI, its auditability,
its trackability.
I view that as just as important
as the overall capability
of what an AI is able to accomplish.
Without that risk mitigation
and without that transparency,
there is not going to be
any trust between the human
who's using that tool and the tool.
At the end of the day,
a human being is always
going to be the one who's
on the hook for a decision
that is made by some
sort of AI based tool.
The heart of AI success,
long-term AI success.
I think that's built at the intersection
of this new emerging technology
and the human beings who
are going to be using it.
A key part of adoption of any
new technology is the humans
who use it.
If you give me a saw,
if you give my dad a saw
and you ask us to build a table,
his is going to be better.
He is better at that type of tool making.
It's always important to
remember there's a human being
at the other end of software.
And so consistent refresher training,
as this new technology
continues to develop,
this is paramount for critical ongoing,
it's critical to ongoing success.
And so as AI becomes more
integrated into IT workflows,
into endpoint management workflows,
organizations have to be
proactive in preparing the people
who are going to be using those
tools to not only use them
effectively, but to oversee them
and manage those tools effectively.
There is a human layer
that is necessary there
to understand, to interpret,
and to question AI driven outputs
so that we can use these
systems not just efficiently,
but also safely.
I think we envision a world
where endpoint management
becomes less in terms of human skillset.
You know, to use another
metaphor, it's not
so much about playing the
individual instruments
of the orchestra, it's about
conducting the entirety
of the orchestra at large.
And so IT staff need to be
trained to understand where
and how AI is being applied.
They need to understand
how to interpret AI outputs
as well as question them.
I would argue that the time
to question them is always,
because blind trust in
AI decisions does lead
to significant risk, much in the same way
that web designers use
dark patterns to influence
where our eyes are drawn
and where we're most likely to click.
In the same way that
early versions of iOS,
maybe before it was actually called iOS,
had sort of a textured look to it,
encouraging you to kind of
interact with the screen.
A lot of the times LLMs give
you overwhelmingly positive
responses to anodyne milk
toast queries and suggestions,
and so questioning, and
that's all done of course to,
you know, create this positive
feeling in the actual user
so that they come back and
they want to use it more,
which is not necessarily
the goal that you might
want to have when managing endpoints
and trying to improve business efficiency.
And so given the quickly
evolving AI landscape,
that continuous skill
development is critical.
Ongoing education, best practice
groups, regular meetings
for cross-functional knowledge sharing.
I think having maybe a
weekly or a monthly meeting
where a portion of that
is what is the best thing,
best suggestion that you had
from an interaction with AI,
and then what is the
worst thing that happened,
the worst thing that an AI suggested
to you this week or this month.
And that helps level set every,
that helps level set amongst the team.
Now in conclusion,
integrating new technology
is really difficult.
AI is new, it's exciting,
it's having a momentous impact
on how all of us work, but
it's also having an impact
on how our individual devices are managed.
That's important to remember
that tangible long-term
benefits resulting from the
integration of any technology
are going to come from
come down to how we align
human expertise.
Sorry, I don't know why this is,
I'm waving this around too much.
I think it's a little too sensitive.
So training should always
emphasize the importance
of a human being in the loop model,
sorry, where AI is
augmenting human knowledge
and judgment, not substituting
it and not replacing it.
And so this is where Ninja One is headed.
Autonomous endpoint
management, lessening the need
for human involvement for the most common
and the most annoying tasks,
freeing up those resources
so you can work and
think more strategically,
taking a less experienced
technician, allowing them
to operate at a higher level
and putting up those guardrails to prevent
dangerous solutions, dangerous decisions
from being implemented through the power
of endpoint management.
Thank you everyone for being here.
If you wanna chat a little
bit more about this,
come visit us at Booth
1216, right over there.
My name is Jeff Hunter
and thank you very much
for being here. Take care.